[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with jake wallace simon's editor of the
jewish chronicle and nancy fielder
editor of the sheffield star where they
both are waiting raring to go so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
well the observer reports boris johnson
is facing a fury from farmers and
environmentalists over his new food
strategy which has stripped out some
recommendations from the government's
food czar
the times leads on the same story but
says the new plans are a win for the
farming lobby which has opposed plowing
large amounts of the farming budget into
rewilding
meanwhile the pm is facing divisions
amongst his mps and ministers over tax
cuts that's on the front of the sunday
telegraph
the mirror reports on a meeting between
justice secretary dominic raab and the
mother of toddler james bulger who was
merged in 1993 ahead of a parole hearing
for one of his killers
the express leads on calls for prince
charles to stay out of politics after he
reportedly branded the government's
rwanda migrant scheme appalling
and the star claims offenders are being
told to carry out their community
service orders from home with many
knitting hats and scarves
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by jake
wallace simon's editor of the jewish
chronicle and nancy fielder editor of
the sheffield star welcome to both of
you let's start with the sunday times
and uh the headline on the front page
there johnson turns his back on
green agenda and this is the accusation
that he's scaled back plans to rewild
the country um and the government's
retreating from this green agenda jake
take us into this story
well the background to this of course is
the cost of living crisis which is being
exacerbated by the war in ukraine which
continues
a pace that's putting a big squeeze on
the cost of living and in particular the
cost of food now the government had
planned to plow 800 million pounds
into
subsidies for farmers to encourage them
to use their precious agricultural land
for rewiring so to create new wetlands
and and other sorts of uh places for for
new ecosystems and wildlife to flourish
and not to produce food
but now the government apparently is
cutting back on this uh cutting it back
to 50 million pounds which is a huge
reduction
um to allow farmers to focus more on
producing food
which farmers are very keen on obviously
it allows them to do what they want to
do
sell food make more money and be in
control of their businesses and it's
important to recognize uh that we
currently make only 64 of our food in
this country and import the rest so
we're very vulnerable
on food from outside the uk and when
this is threatened by war or other
global unrest that puts us in a very
vulnerable position and so i think
overall this probably is a good move for
the government to cut back on those on
those green products for the moment to
focus on making sure that the cost of
living crisis is contained particularly
with respect to the food on our plate
but uh we read nancy that uh
conservation groups have described
what they're saying is a u-turn is a
massive betrayal and others have
suggested a link to the tiverton and
honest and by-election due to be held in
uh devon on june 23rd
that's right it does seem interesting
timing and we've got a prime minister
and a government who are very good at
their interest in timing they see where
they need to win votes and they see an
imminent election
um caused by one of their own mps
behaving really badly in parliament and
they decide that suddenly they need to
woo the farmers and whether or not we
believe this is the right policy it's
just blatant case of trying to win votes
and what will they do straight after
will they enforce that we've seen many
many occasions where it hasn't actually
pushed through it's rolled out for an
election and it wins the votes but it
doesn't actually appear and let's be
honest about this the cost of living is
awful there are hugely devastating
impacts on every family in the country
that we will know about go into a little
bit but is climate change and is
rewilding and are green issues always
going to be the first to go with the
agenda because it really feels like it
and before the last election boris
johnson was all over and making the
right noises but yet again it's been
thrown to one side as if it really
doesn't matter when there's more
important issues for him which are
getting the winning back the confidence
of a certain area so that his mps
believe in him after last week's vote of
no confidence that went through just by
the skin of his teeth although he
doesn't like to admit it
and the observer with the the same uh
story or the same theme and they're
looking at well what they're describing
as fury over post-brexit food strategy
um
what is this article actually focusing
on though jake
well i mean this article takes an
entirely different angle on the same
story in fact doesn't seem to match up
very well to the sunday times article
the observer has got an interview with
the national farmers union president
where she slams the government saying
that the
the post-brexit subsidies which the
government was so was supposed to
provide to compensate for the lack of
money from the eu after he left the eu
have failed to properly materialize
that's point number one and also seems
to be saying that the government is
putting farmers under pressure to set
aside their land for environmental
purposes uh without properly
compensating for them so it seems to
contradict the sunday times article a
bit but i think as um as nancy said this
does show that uh politics is being is
being played with the farmers at the
moment because the tibetan holiday
election is coming up it's in a rural
area of the west country and farmer
farming vote matters there and so while
the government is trying to woo farmers
the observer is trying to whip them up
and make them vote against the
government um to overturn the
government's 24 000 majority in favor of
the liberal democrats um and so it's
quite hard to make out exactly what's
going on here but certainly there's a
lot of politicking going on uh in
advance of the election that's coming up
yeah so and according to this article
national farmers uh union president
minette batters is saying that uh the
the policy government policy would mean
that farmers wouldn't be able to produce
food
affordably at all um and the essentials
put in their report by henry dimbleby
it's been it's been stripped to the bone
so everything that was useful in the
report has been taken out
nancy that's right
that's right i mean they've cut the
funding about something like one percent
of what they originally promised which
goes back to the point of actually how
reliable and how trustworthy what do
these promises mean are they worth
anything and it is i mean look it's not
easy for any of us but it is not easy
being a farmer now and as we've already
said the amount of food that we produce
locally which is better for everybody
better for the country better the
environment is shrinking it's showing by
about 20
is since the 80s and it continues to
shrink so we do need to support our
farmers we do need to think about the
planet and we do need to think about our
own british countryside but it just
seems that this is a mismatch that isn't
really going to keep anybody happy and
most concerningly it's probably not
going to happen anyway give it a few
weeks and there'll be another u-turn
jake to the sunday express and tell us
how business secretary kwesikua tang is
um looking to help motorists at the pump
well this again is the soaring cost of
petrol we have the landmark the grim
landmark that was passed last week of
the average car now costs more than 100
pounds to fill
and the expresso here is asking
questions about the inconsistency
that's apparent across different petrol
stations up and down the country and
i've experienced this myself you can
drive from one petrol station to the
next often only a few miles apart yet
the difference that the pump is
considerable and there are questions
being asked about why that is and
whether it's possible to
to prevent uh potential profiteering on
the on the part of the energy companies
and so forth but i think the underlying
issue here is that for about 46
of the price that you pay at the pump
goes to the government in tax and this
is something that the government could
very fairly easily and quickly cut back
on uh to save people money uh at the
fuel
as they as they fuel up their cars that
can make a really big difference to
everybody in the country it's something
the government should really be
seriously looking at this time
yes and question has asked the
competitions and markets authorities to
conduct an urgent
investigation um let us quickly look at
the telegraph uh nancy and this story of
uh tax cuts this being a point of uh
division amongst the tories
absolutely and it's yet another crisis
looming for boris johnson because um
there's a general acceptance feeling
that families are struggling at the
minute and actually taxes should be
reduced to help people make ends meet
and it seems that different people
there's all sorts of different anonymous
sources who are leaking information here
but it seems to be there's a general
push for taxes to come down but there is
resistance for it to happen and again i
hate to sound cynical or repetitive but
i feel like when we need a trump card to
be pulled out it will probably be that
taxes are reduced to to cover up
something else that's gone wrong in
government but it isn't something that's
bipolar can get it is something that is
actually really serious and i think this
article describes it as a bit of a
childish row and that the kids maybe the
kids are winning the government should
actually grow up and look at this
seriously rather than just rolling it
out as another card to women voters this
is a really serious issue and it needs
to be looked at properly yes and the
telegraph
understanding that mr sunak will refuse
to cut taxes unless mr johnson
identifies government spending that he
is willing to cut to fund such a move
clearly divisions on that topic jake and
nancy for the moment thank you we are
going to take a break coming up
stay out of politics charles that's on
the front of the express as the future
monarch is chastised by mps stay with us
more
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me jake wallace
simons editor of the jewish chronicle
and nancy fielder editor of the
sheffield star welcome back to both of
you let's have a look at the express
front page a big bold headline stay out
of politics uh charles to what does this
refer jake
well this is the
story that prince charles apparently has
been saying to people that he finds the
government's policy on deporting legal
migrants to rwanda appalling and this is
according to a number of anonymous
sources
oh we seem to be having a
reporting on private conference charles
never would have made these claims um
public
can you hear me
uh let's let's cross to nancy uh jake
why would you sort out your your sound
um so nancy yes as jake was saying this
is referring to reported comments from
prince charles suggesting that uh he
thinks the random policy is appalling
this is that's true
and again unnamed sources quite a few
sources by the looks of it but all
unnamed nobody willing to go up against
the future king by the looks of it um
and many of the papers taking the view
that the future monarch should keep out
of politics and it's quite an
interesting debate i mean none of us
really know what the queen thinks about
most subjects do we but we certainly
know what charles thinks about a lot of
them but actually a lot of them are
perhaps less political than you might
think i mean he said there was a clip on
sky earlier and where he was talking
about actually when he really cared he
did say past tense and we really cared
about the inner cities and actually what
was happening to the young people then
what could be done to support them we
know he's a massive supporter of
climate
and helping our planet and helping the
environment but we don't really know
what the queen thinks and there is a
view that somebody who is edging closer
and closer to taking the throne should
just keep his opinions to himself but
i'm not sure he's going to it doesn't
strike me as a sort of character who's
going to quietly sit on the phone and
not make comments on things jake the
message is clear though to to butt out
of politics the mail the headline there
we will not back down on rwanda charles
no future king really wants to see this
kind of headline he is supposed the
monarch is supposed to be politically
neutral the queen showed a wonderful
example of that or has shown a wonderful
example of that for 70 years you know in
inch perfect she hasn't put a foot wrong
and charles already has made blunder
after blunder on on green issues on and
now on um on the rwanda issue
and i think that there's a there's a
grave mistake in in jumping the gun and
seeing the rwanda policy as being
inherently immoral
because we must remember that what it's
doing is targeting people who are
risking their lives to come to britain
without necessarily being refugees but
simply being economic migrants and we're
seeing people dying in the channel
making the dangerous journey across
europe funding uh putting money into the
pockets of people traffickers and
funding this horrible uh human
trafficking uh
um
business
and really the
deportation to rwanda is a way of
targeting that human suffering and it
should be recognized as such
nancy take us to the mirror um they're
reporting that uh
james bulger dominic rabber gives hope
of justice at last this is the james
bolder murder um
story from uh well uh over 25 years ago
29 year fight
what's the latest on this
yes i mean we all remember that day
anybody anybody who was around and i was
very small child but we all remember the
horrific murder and the court case and
everything that's ensued and they
haven't really been out of the
newspapers since um for obvious reasons
but quite incredibly this is apparently
the first time that a senior politician
has actually agreed to meet jama
bulger's mom um and she wants her son's
killers in jail there's a parole hearing
coming up for one of them and she
categorically wants him to say in there
she believes that um he should and
apparently she had just two days to
prepare sort of a statement about the
impact the personal impact
that the original crime has caused on
her and her family and it i mean it's
just horrendous it is the most horrific
crime
yeah one that that we all remember is as
you say
but very very good